comme les régions voisines s'est
réveillé sous une couche de glace les
branches sont tombées pendant toute la
nuit ça fait très prudent le parc La
Fontaine est méconnaissable partout
c'est comme un centre de guerre
des branches et des arbres matures
renversés par le poids de 30 mm de pluie
vers glaçons
incroyable ça tombait partout
mon Dieu c'était vraiment effrayant les
débris ont donné des maux de tête aux
automobilistes cette femme découvre la
mauvaise surprise sa voiture est
lourdement dommagée elle déplore le
manque de soutien de son assureur je me
suis retrouvé avec mes propres problèmes
j'ai pas trouvé ça très agréable sur
l'île de Montréal près de la moitié des
maisons étaient privés d'électricité en
matinée
faut être très sensible à ça Montréal et
dévasté présentement une crise qui
touche également la montée régie un
homme de 60 ans il a laissé sa vie la
branche qu'il coupait lui est tombée
dessus peut pas avoir une meilleure
justification pour dire à tous les
Québécois d'être prudent que ça soit
avec les branches d'arbres que ça soit
bien sûr avec les fils François Legault
s'est entretenu avec les dirigeants
d'Hydro-Québec avant de constater les
dégâts dans la liste de la ville pour
accélérer le nettoyage la mer est
splende demande au Montréal est de
déplacer leur véhicule il y a pas de
contravention aujourd'hui juste un
Trudeau s'est déplacé dans le quartier
Villeré ou une chute de glace la
surprise sans conséquence toutefois
au plus fort des pannes un million
200000 foyers canadiens ont manqué
d'électricité la PDG d’hydro-québec se
fit Brochu discrète depuis l'annonce de
sa démission a défendu la fiabilité du
réseau les autorités prévoient établir
les trois quarts des pannes d'ici
vendredi soir ça s'est concentré
beaucoup dans la région de Montréal la
région de l'Outaouais la région de la
mort au terrigie c'est vraiment le
qu'est-ce qui est au nord au sud près du
fleuve qui est vraiment eu davantage de
dégâts
si les pilons électriques ont tenu le
coup des milliers de fil se sont
affaissés quelques 1100 monteurs de
lignes d'Hydro-Québec sont à pied
d'oeuvre pour rebrancher tout le monde
on est strie le retour du courant en
matinée a permis d'envoyer des renforts
vers les zones rouges en fait tout le
temps
hydro-qué
si on essaie d'appeler il y a aucun
réseau autre contrecoup les principaux
réseaux de téléphonie ont connu des
ratés tout au long de la journée on
n'avait pas accès dans le fond aucun
réseau enfin c'est ça s'il y avait un
urgence je sais pas qu'est-ce qu'on
aurait fait le réchauffement des
températures en journée a provoqué des
chutes de glace dangereuses forçant même
la fermeture partielle du pont Champlain
un peu partout des Halles de chaleur ont
ouvert leurs portes pour se réchauffer
mais aussi pour charger les téléphones à
cannelés en Outaouais on sert même des
repas chauds
et le coeur des gens l'occasion de se
serrer les coudes entre voisins ton vois
aller charger les ordinateurs chez les
voisins qui ont de l'électricité sinon
ça y est c'est un beau côté là toujours
la solidarité entre nous c'est cool ça
réveille écrit quelque chose de bien
aussi une solidarité bienvenue pour ceux
qui passeront la fin de semaine de
Pâques sans électricité ici
Jean-Philippe Radio-Canada Montréal